today we're going to be drawing Disney
characters from memory from my brain I
hope I do okay I depends which movies
they are cuz some of them I don't know
oh boy are you serious right now
Wow a character I know that guy I
haven't seen 100 just draw a Dwayne the
rock Johnson I mean I I know kind of
what this what this character looks like
he's like big and yeah anyway again do
strong Dwayne the rock Johnson shirtless
and you're there so I think he's got
like an oval face Yeah right I think
he's like no does he have a nose I think
he has a big nose I remember she has
like these really distinct horns I know
she has like a very narrow lovely
triangle thing yes like a very angular
angular this is bad I know she's green
and she looks like Angelina Jolie oh god
I look like him at all okay okay so I
think he's got like the top hat right
yeah he's got he's definitely got a top
hat okay but it's like a small top hat
and then I think his body he's got a
little bean body and a vest I think and
probably like a bowtie he's like a
little dapper Dapper dude but he's like
wider right
how do you square he's kind of a square
yes cuz I'm doing him as it like a
series of spheres uh-oh his head's gotta
be huge Disney cartoons of those big old
heads
I think he's gonna just give a nose I
feel like he has a nose like a big nose
like in my mind he's looking like Joe
Camel like he's got Joe camels by camel
nose kind of um I love Maleficent
because her whole reason for being evil
is that she didn't get invited to a
birthday party I love her he has very
beautiful hair right it's like long like
long and flowing looks like Dwayne the
rock Johnson's hair right he has lots of
cool tattoos with like his like life on
them or something like every time you
did something cool do the tattoos like
move yes they do I do know that wait
what props does he have
he has a it's like a hook right yeah oh
yeah I'm like oh I don't know her
actually I had to do I'm drawing him and
he's not looking like what's in my head
he's got like a little vest right like a
1920s suit okay and he's got gloves so
they gave him gloves because Felix the
Cat had black hands and whenever his
hand went over his body it would
disappear
so they started giving cartoon
characters white gloves the other came I
don't think so oh I'm gonna draw on the
king cuz it just looks like it looks
right for me he's built right yeah not
like he's not like rock built he's not
no he's like even filter than rock but I
don't think that's the rocks fault
oh no it's animated listen it's never
the rocks fall I'm gonna give him
antenna I know he didn't have one but
it's just gonna make my picture look
more like I wanted to look okay I think
I just drew an alien oh no he's gotta
wear pants right he's gotta wear pants
I'm feeling good about this I'm not
feeling good about this green and purple
she's like oh she is Queen of those
colors a green woman god I'm having a
hard time oh gosh she's looking nice no
story oh that's right he's got like a
like a puka shell necklace right but he
he'd stole it from Moana okay I don't
care where you got it I just I don't
care where he just gotta I gotta make
him shine I mean they can blush
I still got a color
oh well great Jackie give me a second
this is what happens when a cartoonist
goes up against an animator you
animators are so fast
so I remember her being incredibly
triangular like the most defining
feature of her and her silhouette is
longhorns which I hope I got right if I
didn't I will be very Oh bad character
designer her body is the thing I just
don't remember the most I think it's
just like a I think oh he is just cloak
yeah like she's mostly clothed I don't
remember seeing her legs okay he looks
like the planters peanut guy or whatever
yeah I think that's a pretty accurate
description okay I think I'm just
drawing that person like I don't know if
this is what Jiminy Cricket looks oh
that doesn't look great no I'm just
gonna draw my own original character my
own gonna brighten Seavers original
Jiminy Cricket I'm already there I've
been drawing an original alien cook it
for a while man you got the right idea
man I don't know what I've been doing I
would say that a cartoonist usually
works in static images where as an
animator would work in moving images do
you think that's appropriate to say yeah
sure are you just humoring me a little
bit okay you know what this looks like
Jiminy Cricket I'm gonna go the extra
mile start giving him some like shading
his lady she says no she's the bad lady
and she's hard to drive she is
incredibly hard to go oh the one thing I
remember she has like these green things
these like weird ring is on our Lauren
what's the name of the alien from the
Flintstones kazoo is this so weird how
you can have like such a vivid idea of
what a character looks like in your head
and then you got a draw but then once
it's actually cut push comes to shove to
like recreate it it's like you just
can't yeah I've done oh you're going on
right now I think this is gonna get
let's get another hour I'm missing
plenty I'm missing so much does it yeah
I like I think it's like perfect and if
anyone has critiques for me don't tell
me them alright I'm done okay
all right I want to be confident I think
I got like the feel of her down but I am
not sure about that stuff I think that I
have drawn Queen Amidala from Star Wars
but just green like she's real sick yeah
his hook is a lot bigger than I thought
it would wait that's his hook
yeah he's got a lot of tattoos yeah
that's why I didn't really like a lot of
tattoos I knew that and I just didn't
want to do it
yeah that's my excuse also I drew him
with a bald spot Wow he's got a full
head of hair no I forgot her collar this
is not this thing that I have done at oh
my god okay I knew that I was really
thinking about the Queen from Snow White
mine looks like a like Party City
Halloween store costume okay yeah that's
uh you know what sort of yeah I got the
color counter kind of good oh he's got
an umbrella umbrella it's got a little
spat fun he does look like Joe Camel a
little bit though
the top hats bigger it's like more of a
Mad Hatter top hat yes also he's wearing
like a little blazer you know what I'm
not like a shame though like I got the
nose
I think the eye shape was kind of good
yeah he did it all right I don't think I
did all right but I think I did close I
did his vest
it's like without watching this movie in
like 20 years
oh great both thought that her her horns
were sort of stripy which they are yeah
they are a little bit straight oh nice
trophy yours looks a lot like a villain
from the Powerpuff Girls or something
you've got like a fan of the Powerpuff
Girls I think it's the oh you did great
I told you I gave him a bald spot
because I thought for some reason he had
a bald spot listen if I were casting it
I would have Danny DeVito play yeah
everything right yeah
if the labs are up my talent or at the
bigger this is a pretty good picture oh
my god is the thing okay so it's not a
bad picture it's just like it's not at
all like what I was expecting you got
his face better than me I think I think
I had to get his face you did get his
face and his hat I think you got his
energy more like there's a lot of
character in yours it's good I'm just
the bald spot really it really is a hot
spot like you I haven't seen the movie
Jackie you know what I drew him older I
drew like retirement age the later years
yeah yeah yeah a lot of retirement hi
I'm Brett hi I'm Jason
we are redrawing cartoon characters from
memory specifically Pokemon can I make a
confession I've never seen Pokemon oh my
god I'm old Jackie you don't look a day
over my age okay I got this I don't got
a gap the poor in be poor e on its part
it's an eeveelution use the water stone
to get it from evey I have no idea what
any of those words mean
he has spiky hair yeah yes baby the
update is look I feel like every few
years so they do generation you so I
remember like the og look give me some
clues to the construction okay first of
all blue it's blue it's a water pokemon
okay so it's gonna be like fish features
but not like really hardcore is it like
a fish man no so this Pokemon is closely
resembles like a cat he's like a cat
electro cat it's a mouse house boy as
we've discussed they don't ever look
like the animals they're based on well I
was starting with like a kind of basic
cat construction but it's kind of
turning more into a dog there's nothing
wrong with a little flair of your own I
was one of those kids who like loved
drawing animals so much so I drew all of
the Pokemon I don't think I've ever
drawn yeah she cared about
like he was just a vehicle first to see
cute pokémon I think that what's in my
head is the electro tail yes right I
don't even know if I got that right I
think that's what it looks like I think
I'm drawing a snowman with electro tell
actually how do you get the baseball hat
to not cover the face I'm gonna make
characters don't have like deceptively
big heads I know the like what you're
generally supposed to do in Pokemon is
the guy's name is ash he collects
Pokemon in order to battle against other
Pokemon collectors and they use coin
this is this is just cultural osmosis
here like I don't this is just what I
know from being a person in the world I
think of his body I guess maybe it's
like a sack I don't know it's kind of
got like a slim frame it's kind of
slippery it's not like fat I don't know
the sack of flour yeah he's a sac fly
anyway when you beat someone in Pokemon
you don't get their Pokemon you don't
you just get bird you get the bragging
rights what happens that's it when you
defeat someone in chess you don't get
their chess pieces you just get bragging
don't oh my god
oh my god I love Pokemon because it's
just you could just go as a child and
explore the world and your mom's just
like okay I think that hat is red and
white if any is like a green symbol on
it so Vaporeon is the evolved form of
Eevee okay and Eevee is this Pokemon
that's really popular because one
Eevee's adorable okay Pikachu is an
electric pokemon the evolved form of
Pichu in the pre-evolved form of right
you got put goop against him and -
because he's like one of the only
pokemons that like has like multiple
evolutions fun fact Pikachu can learn
the move surf so this is not an
inaccurate thing I'm drying doesn't he
just say Pikachu could you could you do
it for us Jason do you know disco there
we go there you go that goes my the
extent of my knowledge on Pikachu all
right well if these this extra time I
have I'm gonna start drawing Ryan or
Ryan Reynolds Pikachu oh sure in what
situation would you use
of the chorion against fire type Pokemon
not against an electric-type pokémon no
I would yeah so ash basically just is on
this never-ending quest to be the
ultimate pokemon master but he's a fool
who only catches like five pokemon and
he catches like the worst pokemon yeah I
am drawing something very interesting
but it is most definitely not a Vaporeon
I kind of wish again mine was more
simplified and cuter cuz I feel like I'm
gonna see what it really looks like and
I'm gonna be like you know what all that
time I spent making fun of you should
have been me practicing how to humble
myself yea Glass Houses check ya Glass
Houses hubris all that I give them an A
for Alvin like robots
ok I'm done there's no pose it's just a
like it looks like he's Flat Stanley but
oh my god his arm is so long I'm so
that's it whatever done I don't stop
that's pretty darn accurate with the
cartoon Pikachu I'm not gonna lie pretty
embarrassing if I was like way off the
mark with this one I think if you look
at mine
you can say that is Pikachu yeah I don't
think I got the I guess the shape of
Pikachu right at all I mean it's not
good drawing but I think that it is ash
I think I got like the feel of him like
like a fan art drawing of him but I'd oh
I did him so dirty on the outfit I'm so
sorry
I love Pokemon I think I did pretty okay
if it doesn't look like beforehand I
think the drawings really cute so - both
ah
not Vaporeon but also not quite really a
great drawing well you know what it
really do be like that they'd be like
that sometimes it's true it's true
oh yeah I actually did kind of better
than I thought I would you know I tried
my best and that's all that matters
oh yeah oh come on spitting image looks
exactly like him
I should have given his eyes a little
bit more character but yeah I think it
still looks like a future oh I I think I
didn't do horrible okay how am I
supposed to like remember all the like
eeveelutions you know so if anyone has
anything to say to me don't because I'm
really sensitive and it's gonna hurt my
feelings mine is not correct at all ah
but it's a lot closer than I thought it
was going to be you got the shirt and
the spirit do it better his best it
looks so comfortable they gave them a
puffy sort of Marty McFly vest
yours is definitely a little bit more I
think accurate yours looks like water
Garfield I love it if Garfield was a
water type that's what this because you
said it's like a water cat what are you
can when I think water cat I think well
Garfield this because shoots pretty
accurate yours is actually really close
yeah like it's it's it's like it's I
forgot the whole head nod do you even
remembered like the the bifurcated tail
we like both remembered similar things
yeah pants look like this and he
definitely has like this going on but I
like he's got like battle scars all over
him like these brown marks I'd rather
these needs to draw I'm gonna do some
hatching and lining you are much closer
I think you're just good for someone who
never watched or thank God into Pokemon
from the very bad description I gave you
you really made it work I really love
the antenna right it's I just don't
understand do fish have antennae
something do I know more about Pokemon
that I do fish right yeah put us
together
yeah put us together we're the perfect
person we would be water gym leaders I
don't know what that means but I'm in
that means we're the best at water
pokemon kind of there's more than gym
leaders there's a lot of them there's
the Elite Four
okay hi I'm Sarah hey I'm Kira we are
going to be drawing SpongeBob characters
from memory yeah
did you grow up on SpongeBob you did
punch Bob was like right at the end of
my kid cartoon watching career like it
was Ren and Stimpy
and then like I discovered girls so like
that should do it I feel about that too
bad
who is Andy yeah that's okay I remember
mr. Krabs patrick star patrick star
patrick star he is a starfish oh he sure
is
I wonder what gave it away you know what
his body shape is egg it's like Oh or
like a baseball I feel like sort of he's
got a big old big ol body little T limbs
I've seen the spongebob movie and never
watched the show no early to watch it
every day as a kid I don't know who's ND
is okay so sandy is the squirrel who
lives machine this big water she is in
the she's in a suit yeah see then this
sort of it's got like a big glass dome
does he have a nose well you're just
gonna have to draw I didn't see if he's
not going to help me but not this time
okay I don't think your heads like too
big she wears like mittens
she's got boots her body is pill-shaped
pills shapes kind of pill shaped yeah
yeah I like also how his clothes if I
remember correctly just kind of there
just like on his body like there's not
there's not much of volume I guess
they're just lines on an egg you know
what's weird is I can't remember her
tail now but like she's got to have a
tailor I eat like that saw that squirrel
is yeah I don't remember the tail being
like a prominent feature in her design
are you more of a spongebob or are you
more of a Patrick like my personality I
don't like it that's not a lot of
choices I feel like I'm hard-working
like spongebob but I do sometimes feel
like a Patrick like doesn't everyone
have a little Patrick inside of them
yeah a big cheeks she's got the buck
teeth I know that for sure
this she basically looked like like Bugs
Bunny with short ears yes actually
that's not totally inaccurate I think
I definitely made him way cuter than he
actually - I'm so really cute am I crazy
or does he have a big belt and does any
wear it like all just got one look and
it's crab baby Patrick doesn't really
have a lot of clothes
yeah he's shirtless mm-hmm at least I'm
putting him shirtless and he's got pants
and I want to say that they're dark
purple you're not going to tell me if
I'm right
are they you should try it out yeah he's
gonna give her a tail I don't think she
has I don't think she has no she does
have a tail she's gonna have a tail
yeah why can't I think of a tail does he
have anything else on his face well yeah
yes eyes obviously come on
something that makes mr. Krabs like one
of the best crab designs in animation is
his eyes they're just like super
memorable and unique like if you saw a
silhouette of him you would instantly
recognize it I can't remember if his
pants like actually go onto his legs i
ìm turn over that to I think like a
little bit yeah I just gave him like a
little shorts
so I'm her limbs being tubular and kind
of narrow she's not like a buff squirrel
she's got sort of a tiny head inside of
this big spacesuit tiny head it's crazy
how you can like watch a cartoon a
million times and like stare at these
cartoon characters forever but then the
moment someone's like draw it out you're
like I can't Wow okay oh God I'm almost
done
oh my god you know why Jackie because I
kept it simple oh well I should have
done what you were doing I'm even gonna
shade him ya know ya know yep doesn't
she I think she has a bow like on the
outside of her irrelevant of her helmet
I think she does or a flower when I draw
a flower is wrong what looks like a bow
to me
alright you draw a bow I'll draw a
flower okay I think I'm done I'm done -
I know that there's gonna be some
details that I didn't get that I didn't
remember but I feel like overall I feel
like I got the construction right I feel
like the fact that I didn't give him a
nose was the right choice well you know
what now that we're not drawing anymore
III would like to confirm to you that he
doesn't
he does not have a nose how do you think
you did I think I did really good I love
this drawing that I did he looks really
cute he's really happy it's making me
happy and I hope it makes you happy you
sure it will and I hope it makes the
viewers happy I think I got the bit that
they like of a general shape of him down
but I feel like I messed up on the
clothes for sure I'm not sure if I got
his clothes or if this is just like a
wishful thinking look it's just laundry
day for everything's just laundry nabe
all right yeah I did god-awful
I still have no like image of who this
person is in my head other than an
animal and spacesuit yeah I didn't get a
button for some reason Heidi gave him
the belly button oh I forgot he's like
bridges on his back oh yeah I did not
give him little ridges mine does look
like a really really like cute version
of Sam I also did not remember he has
weird little things on his eyes I did
remember those but I was like trying my
hardest to remember what the eye-shine
looks like she does of a tail okay I am
so far K I'm not I'm not far up I'm on a
different planet this is pretty close
that's not bad Oh yours is so much more
accurate this is so cute I love his
claws well this one looks like one that
did that nickelodeon sponsored oh thank
you you gave him like a like you gave
him like gnome pants yeah I love it and
yours is perfect
you might dialed it wait well
I'm perfect you did do full black eyes
as opposed to the white but like you got
the general shape of the face you got
the tin body the flour on the outside I
think you got a lot of it for someone
who's just seen like the movie and like
barely knows it's over ten years ago
really does anything about Spongebob
like this is pretty good we remember the
same things we definitely did
we got the fact that he has a collar and
a pocket sorry guys well he doesn't have
a pocket in this picture we just have
met old Mandela effect so we just
imagined that he had a box but he
doesn't yeah yours is so cute I would
like buy merch with this little crab on
it spongebob
its iconic and it's like we're
definitely permeated our culture and
learning more than most properties I'm
gonna remember it because you spend all
your free time as a child just watching
television what else am I gonna do pay
my taxes I don't have taxes yet I'm a
I'm a kid I had taxes when I was a kid
no I didn't I was gonna be like you were
a really advanced child prodigy hi I'm
Brent hi I'm Jason and today we're gonna
be drawing Looney Tunes characters from
memory our brain that's a big universe I
feel like the human characters are gonna
be hard if there's human characters
Looney Tunes that are hard yeah I don't
think I've ever drawn any lead since I
probably Bugs Bunny as a child oh boy
well let's get into it
his name is Marvin the Martian I have
slippers cemani Sam no Oh No
[Music]
wait oh the turns have tabled so I have
an advantage for ones you're gonna kill
me today yes so he's got massive cheeks
big buck teeth and then the bigger okay
wait a minute maybe I can draw him oh my
god you so maybe I'm great
he's adorable I love aliens I love that
you could only really see his eyes his
voice is fantastic
his voice is the best so here's the
thing Jackie since you don't know feel
free to ask me questions and I will
answer truthfully field day I'm gonna be
nice to you
Susie Oh 76 oh he's the little cowboy
with the big hat and the big mustache I
have all these like big fake cloudy
memories let me put it in your terms
he has chibi construction big head small
body
he's got more human construction than
most cartoon characters like his head is
not ginormous compared to the rest of
his body his ears are like long yeah
he's got long ears does he have like a
little like fuzzy thing on his butt got
like a tail it's funny how as soon as
you start drawing this really I'm gonna
fail but then you start you're like you
know what I can remember surprisingly
well that is some people's experience he
has a big beard right so he has a big
red mustache do you see his mouth ever
and his nose you do see his nose I think
it's just that separation of like the
beard and the mustache creates his mouth
I mean he's a cowboy well Indiana Jones
a cowboy seriously I mean he has like a
cowboy hat doesn't he wear like a little
green skirt he wears a little very very
Spartan yeah it's very Spartan so he has
a big hat bigger than his mustache yes
it's like a comically large hat the
strong is getting even more confusing
than I started I don't remember if he
also has big bushy eyebrows too much
try the big eyebrows yeah if they work
I'm just gonna do what you're doing cuz
I don't like being left out I'm gonna
give him some bushy now he looks mad so
I think that you're accurate cool use of
colors like he's only like black green
and red and wiry wears the red shoes and
the hat right his helmets great it has
red on it
it's like a Spartan helmet it's got like
this if cura says that's what's
happening in on Marvin's bod then that's
what's happening he has like attitude
right oh yeah I don't know if I'm
getting the attitude right he's always a
carrot maybe it's out of the side of his
mouth hold anything in mind he's holding
on for dear life to look like himself
he's usually holding two large guns oh I
don't know how to draw guns good for you
thank you I'm gonna give him a cup a cup
of coffee that's why he's so angry
yeah he's caffeinated all the time in
his other hand it's gonna hold a cat you
said there was a red thing on here so
I'm gonna put a red thing on here oh it
feels like you're sure maybe he doesn't
sure I do you remember him with a shirt
like a little black body and then that
green skirt does he have a shoulder
heads
I don't remember shoulder pads yo he's
got gloves right he has definitely got
gloves I don't know if he has a crotch
her knees but I gave him a crotch he has
a white chest right I don't think so
I gave him a belt I'm pretty sure he has
a belt like a big belt buckle does he
wear a collared shirt no he does he
wears a vest oh he probably has those
cowboy spinning Spurs first he have
whiskers I think he does good I feel
like those would be so annoying to draw
if you're animating in them maybe he
does
it looks weird taking away his whiskers
help me out with the colors I have no
idea what it's alright his moustache and
beard is like a reddish brown his hat I
want to say is a tan guys got that taste
pants I'm done there is Wow okay thanks
Brad like doing a new funny if I don't
think this is any more accurate the
inside of his ears are pink right I
wanna say yes you could really pull this
one out Jason maybe you got this a night
out I'm gonna make his belt gold cuz
he's a cowboy and feeling that's correct
I don't know what color to make it shirt
neither do i I'm gonna go with like an
orange okay then I'm gonna go with the
opposite of that green green ooh that
looks wrong that was very wrong I'm just
gonna go with white now he looks like an
office worker okay I just a white
collared cowboy yeah I just realize I
didn't give him arms I there we go now
he's gone and then he's got a little
sneaker shoes I think this is as good as
it's gonna get I think I did okay I
think I've got the spirit of him I think
a lot of the details I got wrong you
know what they say wrong and strong
strong and wrong okay yeah yeah I feel
like you should have made the mustache
bigger I feel like my mustache your
mustache is very large I think we're
right that he didn't have a shirt I
think that's accurate I love this rabbit
on the right he is the man
[Music]
you got his skirt more accurate than I
did well you got hit his arms his hands
right completely oh you are really close
I remembered his beard being
I mean his moustache being way bigger
and his mouth floats in his mustache
yeah that's weird yeah whatever I just
didn't draw the carrot practicing this
one at his feet so good I his feet are
iconic today we both were on the same
wavelength of like the brush thing on
his head but we weren't quite literally
a brush and all that talk we had about
him not having a shirt look at him he's
in a full well I think he did an amazing
job feeling it I think you do yours is
ridiculously cute well you know what you
win some you lose some you know and as
you taught me before sometimes it'd be
like that hi I'm Kevin hi I'm Jackie
and today we're drawing more Sponge Bob
characters for a memory I know I grew up
with that television so I don't know I
know what spongebob looks like Jason
what shape is I don't know you did such
a great job with Patrick Patrick is like
one shape and Squidward is like four
shapes what forms is he circle right
maybe like a triangle okay
mayhaps a pentagon they have it's
interesting that I don't watch the show
at all but I is no way not to know what
this guy looks like I think I've drawn
this character so many times in my youth
there should be second I've never drawn
have you done research you know what I
have watched a little bit of Spongebob
how did you like it I liked it a lot can
you tell me a little bit about her so
mrs. puff is SpongeBob's driving
instructor and she's at wit's end with
him because he has failed his driving
test like over 100
really his head is quite large thing is
that he has a really big nose like
that's right in it dangle it's like over
his mouth yeah he's got lots of
tentacles oh yeah he's got like he
doesn't have human hands don't draw
human hands okay that's gonna really
freak people out think of like a cereal
box kind of like that shape he's got
like wavy lines on the outside and then
just give him some like Swiss cheese
holes his limbs are kind of to be he's
got like the rubber hose thing going on
I will never get tired of spongebob it's
just like it is ingrained into our
culture into some people's culture and
he's got like big eyes like spongebob
right yeah he's got a big old nose I'm
about much I think that's the only thing
I know about him does he have gloves no
no no cause he's yellow okay so his
hands already stand out the shape of his
head mm-hmm is it like a bullet shape or
is it something different it's like a
mushroom it's like a mushroom imagine a
mushroom you know it's like a bulbous
uh-huh and then it's got the stem okay
next question yes is he wearing clothes
yes he sure is like shirt and pants what
do you think oh no oh this is the limit
of you helping me here it looks like a
cookie wait can I ask you for in hints
are her fins like hands or are they just
like fin
they're like fin feel like buck teeth
all right I think yes bucks he's not
wrong I met okay
oh now right now I got it okay I think I
got it now so I've made an executive
decision I am giving him both a shirt
and pants sounds good I'd support you I
feels no you're right keep it go now I
think you're effing with me no I'm not I
would never do such a thing I'm actually
like really cool and awesome and kind
that makes something a sailor's dress
it's a very good reference day when they
had uniforms that are inspired by like
sailors yeah okay okay does she wear
shoes yes are they fabulous yeah they're
like little high heels I think yeah she
is really tiny like it's like an
interesting take on a Blowfish
which is cool like I don't really think
I've seen any other Blowfish
like hers how old is she she's like
middle-aged does she wear makeup yes
okay you should maybe restart the clock
oh my god I spent too long on the
niceness of the lines I think be able to
color it I have to decide what colors I
want to make him he's a very drab color
I know that you should try all sorts of
colors now you're just actively trying
to screw with me I don't even know find
space for this I Jason do not forget the
time all right I won't forget I'm gonna
come at you in the cup it's not over the
time I should have formatted my drawing
like one of those drawing tutorials
where it's like just draw a square and
I'll be like listening to you
dropping it yeah next time who needs art
school when you can watch BuzzFeed
videos oh wait wait but does she does
she have arms yes though like arm fins
you could take any frame of Spongebob
out of context and probably make a meme
out of it just because there's so much
like character and expression in it
sponge gnar or like caveman spongebob
like when future Sponge Bob goes to the
past and like meets is like caveman
counterpart Wow and sponge gnar is like
Oh what about you Jason you got a
favorite spun by me no I don't know
about the means much sigh audience I
live in the cave don't do that oh my god
can we have a loose - no doesn't look
right I'm coloring in his pants and I
feel like I made a bad decision it's too
late to change it it's too late to
change it you got a Camilla I gotta live
with it but it was wrong yeah
oh this is definitely not mrs. I think I
did really well I think this looks like
the character more than anything else
I've done in this challenge you know
what I'm confident yeah I'm confident in
my decisions I feel someone okay I feel
like the pants were the wrong thing to
do we're gonna find out he doesn't have
pants does he
[Music]
she is so cute like that if adorable you
made her look like a Sailor Scout she's
adorable can I kill it
you did amazing I killed him with a
knight no I'm the real knife I stabbed
him over and over until he bled
misunderstanding me fled until he died
no yes he's like robbing us at lighting
your poi finger point yeah this looks
kind of like the first draft okay before
they refined it yeah they were like they
drew this and they were like this is the
guy and then and then they like quietly
gave it to a real character designer and
they're like I think it's not bad drawer
they're like listen can you clean this
up for Ted here oh yeah exactly that I
forgot he had like the blue eyes oh yeah
oh and socks I didn't know you had socks
Wow I thought his holes were more 3d you
seriously like gave him like divots
into his like skin yeah you did it you
made my gritty live-action remake Bob Oh
would you look at that Wow
I mean you were dead-on was that yeah he
has darker suckers small circles are
darker but you got the purple you didn't
give him a collar on his shirt I was
gonna say that you got the collared
shirt for some reason that's a weird
thing for me to bring you to remember
right she's a lot more hair than I
remember
yeah she doesn't spike I incredibly got
the legs right oh you got them perfect
don't know how you got the color spot-on
thank you yeah spongebob is literally
he's kind of like Mickey Mouse at this
point I don't know who the rest of the
characters of the show is but there's no
way you can avoid knowing oh yeah yeah
you're SpongeBob's gonna beat up my son
you did good Kevin thank you jack I'm so
sorry I never helped you but I really
like not helping you that's weird but
I'll take it
I just think it's funny it's just a good
time to watch you struggle please
everyone likes to watch me struggle
what up gamers it's me your boy pogchamp
and i'm kevin and today we're drawing
90s characters from memory from our
brain our little memories i was born in
the 90s but i don't remember it you had
to be there I was there I was little
baby I was 21
yikes oh there you go
I have his head in my head but I don't
have his body in a head who from Rugrats
Oh his last name is Finster ah I would
bully that kid Jason what shape is
Arnold to head it is obviously football
head nice yeah I know who Dexter is so
I'm happy I'm just trying to remember
all the details that make Dexter Dexter
he's a kid so he's got a big head they
got huge brains yeah let's not go that
far
now am I forgetting his face his eyes
okay so Arnold's like the chill dude so
his eyes are always kind of like he's
got his lids closed like halfway
Nicktoons was always they always had
like the cooler um cartoons Nicktoons
had like ah real monsters and Rugrats
which felt safer always had like adult
jokes and they're hidden in there
somewhere
you know I didn't watch a lot of Rugrats
but the Rugrats that I did watch I
remember not liking his character cuz
he's like he's like whiny right yeah
he's like the worst Rugrats character
what was great about hey Arnold for me
is that hey Arnold took place in like a
city yeah I was born and raised in the
in the Bronx yeah and it was it was
great to see a show that reflected that
I reflected that so the city that's in
hey Arnold is actually a mix between New
York and Seattle which I thought was
super cool so you didn't watch red dress
I watched some of it I don't really
remember it I watched Dexter a lot as a
kid yeah I used to watch it a lot when I
was younger I would say not as a kid
because I mean I was kind of in high
school and getting into college from
Dexter was coming out Rugrats and like
Ren and Stimpy was like the end of my my
nicktoons watching and then you
discovered girls you got a live life
without any shame everybody knows why
incognito mode exists wait what
you know it's funny you never remember
what the feet look like a lot of the
time his boots are hard I don't like I
remember them but I don't think I'm
getting the shape quite right doesn't
you wear like big chunky shoes chunky
Finster am i right ladies we open the
door and let some of these puns out one
thing that I remember very distinctly
about Dexter is he is like super square
the character designs on Rugrats were
like super freaky yeah like they were
vaguely unsettling I think it was
probably a product of its time things
just didn't look right it was like that
the era of squiggle vision yeah I just
pretended like dr. Katz anyone squiggle
vision home movies a thing that I've
struggled with a lot on here is
remembering the small details of
characters clothes I'm totally making
his clothes up right now I think he's
wearing like a flannel shirt underneath
the eye I remember flannel he has
something on his shirt is it a dinosaur
the evidence
his shirts blue I think with color was
his hat that's like a dark blue his hats
red oh and his hair do you remember
anything about his hair he's got blond
hair yeah yeah he's got like big frizzy
hair right he has like big orange hair
he's got like you know when you're
drawing something poofy and it has like
that little circle in the middle of like
where the tiers are or it's like oh yeah
little loops I don't know what I'm going
I think I'm mixing up Chucky and the
aliens from Toy Story the aliens from
Toy Story have like three eyes and are
green Chuckie Finster is a human child
is he though yes I remember actually
asking my mom when I was a kid what
accent Dexter had and she said that it
was a made-up one but I think I think
it's supposed to be like Transylvanian
right GG's look at this beaker all right
I'm in sound French okay oh my god can't
wait to see yours I know I can't wait to
see you too my final touches is this
cigarette and making his eyes kind of
red because it's high so Jason we
feeling more confident about this one um
yeah I I know it looks like Arnold it's
okay he's you know I think it's getting
closer to what he probably looks like I
think I'm doing we gotta stop fiddling
with it just leave it I think I did okay
I think I got a lot of the details wrong
I'm pretty sure the color of his shirts
and his diaper I put him in a diaper he
may be wearing shorts it's Arnold he's
an adult and he's had a hard life
oh that's so good Oh oh my god oh yeah
this Arnold's chill is hey why is this
diaper purple though so I don't know I
feel like he needed a purple diaper I
loved his expression you nailed the
character like that's totally that's
totally I'm jealous
you're the body of your Arnold feels
like the real character design yeah you
gave him like him like a human body
straight-up Anatomy are you disappointed
in me I just thought it's good Kevin
just why wouldn't you I immediately make
the diaper white I did the diaper purple
and as soon as I did that I was like
he's probably wearing shorts yeah yeah I
think your brain is mixing up concepts
yep yeah I love yours no I think it's
great
Thanks I'm not gonna lie to you though I
don't think it's very on model maybe
that's true but I tried my bad you did
try your best you got the dinosaur and
like I said it's not on model but it is
very cute and you were right about yours
it being vaguely unsettling vaguely
unsettling I think I'm more disturbed by
the diapers than anything oh oh no wait
that was blue okay wait I feel like I
remember his hat being now maybe it was
blue I was I did remember a lot of
things yeah I somehow remembered that
his nose was point even though I started
drawing it round you did too yeah I got
the pointy nose and you got the gloves
you got the gloves and the boots the
boots you got the boot I sorta got the
boots did I give him shoes in my drawing
you did you gave him a little purple
shoes okay yours yours is actually like
really close like it's just if Chucky
was pantsless
your design is spot-on except for the
different color of the the feet yeah
yeah that pretty great aren't they
okay so here's the thing there was
something on his shirt but it's a planet
not a dinosaur we both got the glasses
correct though yeah and you got the eye
style right in that it's just the
glasses with the pupils in it yeah I
think it's it's it's simple but it's
deceptively simple on that you've got to
get all those details right or else it's
not Dexter I think we did pretty good
for two people who didn't really watch
programs nobody can tell us that we did
bad except for the internet hi I'm Brent
I'm Jason today we're drawing comic
strip characters from memory I mean I
know some comic strips definitely easier
than comic book yeah if you say comic
book I'd be having a heart attack right
now you're on my turf now Oh too bad
right
he's pretty iconic yeah oh come on I
don't
I only I only know that guy from memes
watch a spare
just gonna do some scribbles and I'm
okay he's got a big nose see the massive
nose isn't 90% of his body knows he's
chill - he's he's usually got like an
eye closed right yeah I think he's I
think I'm seeing that soon Oh what is
this eye look like that's the thing all
Peanuts characters are made up of like
three lines yeah so if you don't get
those lines down there's no hope for you
thank you it's like Riverdale right yeah
not that I watch that show I don't watch
that show no I don't watch that [ __ ] I
grew up during Garfield so this is
almost muscle memory for me if I see it
and it looks nothing like our field
you're gonna be peeved you're gonna be
peeved I mean I remember like you know
he's like this high school dude who
hangs out Jughead usually has like a
sweater on and that's what I'm worried
about is the clothes what is he - yeah I
think like a sweater and like jeans and
usually a sweater has like our on it for
Riverdale okay so what does Garfield
look like
Garfield's a cat his construction is big
head kind of a beam body like a beer
belly he's got like a gut your belly boy
I feel like some of these things are
contradictory to each other
no all right he's just gonna be sleeping
on top of his little doghouse he's got
big feet big feet like like not not like
cat feet wait so he was like here's like
human feet no okay they're like think of
clown shoes like if clown shoes had toes
I don't like that this description makes
me uncomfortable is really like a
supernatural sort of show I've never
seen it dude I just know is loosely
based off the comment
how can one cat be so difficult to draw
what am i drawing what is this oh I
don't understand not so easy to be a
cartoonist now is it Jackie what a mess
this is so I take it you didn't read
Garfield as a kid no read Garfield who's
reading some reason I remember what he
looks like when he dances like he has
his head all the way up and you don't
see his eyes he just sees like little
happy face uh-huh
I'm gonna draw him dancing - there's
poses that I sort of draw a lot so I'll
just be like you know what don't know
how to draw this guy but I do know how
to draw this
I'm gonna draw him sitting with his leg
over his other leg and hope that the
drawing comes out okay I'm just drawing
I'm standing there wait to Snoopy have
like flat kind of feet oh god I feel
like he's got like people feet I drew
him with people feet yeah I don't know
what I'm doing
he just doesn't look like this looks
like an alien he does kind of look like
an alien like he's I feel like the
character has been around so long and
he's been refined so much that he no
longer really looks like a cat yeah just
looks like Garfield what dog it is a
newbie I don't know oh okay herb eels
they like sad eyes right am i thinking
of like a my brain refuses to make this
into a thing but you've seen Garfield
before I have but I've never looked at
him I just oh wait you know what I think
his ears are together that feels like
it's correct yes
his ears are together I'm some kind of
genius as I'm drawing this and I'm
realizing that hands are definitely one
of the hardest things to draw okay I
don't know what his attitude is he's
sassy and my drawing yeah he is very
sexy what are you doing for your drawing
that's like like stylistically okay it's
kind of a mix of what I remember from
the comic style and just general cartoon
meanness what characters did you grow up
drawing Sailor Moon no yeah but you know
what we don't have to color anything his
guess what he's black and white back and
white because he happy think tongue
though I mean if you were gonna include
that tongue then I guess yeah I think he
has a song his house is red and that's
all I need to draw I kind of want to
make the lines smoother it kind of felt
like when he was drawing them he drew
them what's like a smooth line like I
did them very yeah they were very
gestural yeah like lines what I liked
about Archie from what I can remember of
him is he's really happy looking
everyone in that comic just looks so
happy
what era does it take place in obviously
a happier time like a lot Jackie I'm
feeling pretty good about this
it's
this is not okay why is it not okay she
someone should not nobody should be
forced to look at what I'm doing Oh
Jackie I've never seen you go through
this many emotions before I'm very
stressed out he's horrifying I've never
seen such a monstrous creation come out
of my own hands okay drew three versions
of Snoopy you threw three words Easy's
is gonna be super accurate does he have
like those things that dogs have the
little spots no no okay I don't think so
okay and his eyes are always closed I
think he's pretty minimalist okay stop
overthinking this Jason finish your
drawing it's done are you done yeah I
don't know what else to do to it how
about we have a positive attitude how
about that hey guys I'm done with my
drawing I love Garfield what a guy what
a guy that Garfield
he hates Monday
I drew guy let's calm Archie he's got
freckles and a big R on his shirt and
that's all I remember from Archie so I
feel great yeah like his five fingers
you got these the peanuts dancing is
spot-on yeah okay that's the thing I
remember I was like you had to do that
little lady that yeah let's dance it's
not fair
what do you mean looks just like him
yeah cuz I grew up drawing Garfield Wow
you gave him some disturbingly human eye
you I just noticed his feet his feet are
frightening Jackie I said he had
human-like feet and you literally gave
him human feet this is like ridiculously
appealing he's got an arm freckles we
remember
[Music]
yeah yeah okay he's got like a big
expressive mouth he's got he does Wow
okay I think yours is way closer than
mine I mean with the you have a caller
he does have a caller yeah he's got
freckles yes oh we did have whiskers but
they're up on his head they're like on
the side of his head why does yours look
so much Garfield Garfield is such a
weird-looking cat he is a weird-looking
cat it's because it's you know 40 years
of refining the character they just
becomes more and more abstract he also
had did you say he had heron he had I
know I thought in your head like
whiskers is what I was thinking but he
has eyebrows that I did yes I guess he
has eyebrows yeah
he does have thick eyebrows yeah got
thick eyebrows I was way off on the hair
his mouth thing was so weird right that
was the one thing that I remember the
most about him was his mouth and how
they constructed it like Garfield he's
my enemy now how can you not like girls
Garfield has made an enemy today Wow
yeah Garfield is the most beloved
cartoon cat in history that's not true
Hello Kitty would like something to say
Snoopy yeah he's been perfected by
Schulz over decades of comic drawing
there's some kind of beauty in that
simplicity you get like you just get him
down to his basic forms you know his
iconic shapes yeah and he's he's
unforgettable you know except when you
have to draw them from memory guess what
Kevin what today we are drawing Pixar
characters from from our brain it's
funny because the minute that I heard of
his Pixar everything blanks out of my
mind yeah yeah I mean you say Pixar and
it's like you know every kind of scene
Toy Story yeah feel like I've seen most
Pixar movies as a kid your character
today is all Frederickson from up
I may have a distinct advantage I have a
t-shirt of him no okay
he is complicated yeah I don't wanna
draw him can we
Matt give us another one nope okay um
let's start the head yeah I haven't
watched this movie in a long time so I
really gotta remember he's got
binoculars fries yeah I recall just
gonna rely on the cuteness factor again
if you do it wrong but you make it cute
sometimes it's okay it's just like
murder wait say that again
so hey Jun what's your favorite Pixar
movie that's a loaded question I mean I
really like ratatouille actually yeah
yeah it's really good ratatouille is
solid but I feel like it's not really
the one people pick when they talk about
their favorite my favorite Pixar movie
is really quali for me wall-e was like a
little preachy really I absolutely loved
it I watched it in all its ass like this
movie barely has any sound yeah and it's
like it's doing it for me do you
remember what Wally's purpose is to find
vegetation no no to like squeeze things
and box yeah yeah so he's got like a
little trash compactor he's a triangle
right he's a square boy I think he's a
rhombus he has like underwear on like he
has like a barrel body and then undies
well cuz he's an action figure so he has
to have points of articulation you need
points of articulation he has like three
fingers right yeah you know oh and and
he has like a roach friend yes that he
keeps in his box did Toy Story make you
cry I don't think the first Toy Story
made me cry I think I was a kid so I was
probably like I don't have emotions yet
cried in the second one super hard yeah
the montage it's just so sad what's
what's keeping the binoculars on the box
yeah that's why is it just like there's
some mic mechanism that causes the that
lets the eyes curl a little bit oh yeah
and Moe yeah this is feeling a lot
harder than I thought no not we got this
I'm feeling good about this pose I'm
feeling good about the construction and
now it's just the details it's just
where it all falls apart yes this is
like looking more like grunkle Stan from
gravity falls no square men oh you know
what I remember that's a really weird
detail he has the swirl on his chin Oh
does he remember you or is it
does he now that you're questioning no
not sure no he very well may I just I
don't feel like I tricked you
ah yeah this work gets tough man I don't
like 100 all robots like a whole lot
right now I'm just drawing binoculars on
a box yeah he doesn't have hair right
the hair is so hard to remember I'm just
improvising he has that thing that
astronauts right it's over his head oh
yeah yeah the good thing good thing okay
he has like a battery schematic on them
right I mean like to let you know how
much energy energy yes yeah we yeah he's
got the Sun thing I can't remember this
character from the knees down but I know
he has like army tank wheels kind of
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah he's got like
tank treads feel like he's got like like
his his legs are kind of like bent under
him from said I don't know what to call
these types of feet he's like boom feet
so he has boots I'm like so hesitant to
compare to any details I think maybe we
should stop trying no no we have to keep
going to infinity and beyond Jackie
Jackie come back whoo I got a good
little detail do you remember he has
like a little laser thing in between and
that's how he cuts things oh I don't
like a little laser diet I didn't know
that yeah that doesn't look right but
you know what I'm gonna go for it
Jackie come on how you doing Jason I
think I'm almost there
you know I drew a Wally like substance
holy like
okay time to color alright
yeah very dull but I'm kind of making
him bright I think you're gonna do way
better at this than me cuz I'm really
not confident I'm giving him blue gloves
even though I'm gonna give him some
highlights and like chrome highlights
you're already on highlights yeah get on
my level I feel like there's so much
wrong with this I'm just kind of making
it up and hopefully it looks okay okay I
think that's as far as I'm gonna get I
think I did super good
I don't remember ever drawing wall-e but
he's like he's pretty simple like if you
can draw a couple of inanimate objects I
think you're like already 90% of the way
there uh-huh
so I think I captured this essence but I
kind of made him into more of a
commercial yeah I I think I got his
essence as well but I'm sure all the
details are wrong
yeah I think once I see what he looks
like I'm gonna feel like just a just a
big old fool yeah can't wait to reveal
this one oh yeah oh man yours looks a
little sinister yeah oh my god to shave
you got him like way closer than I did
your car looks like he has had enough of
business
screw you corporate America just looking
at yours I can tell you what's wrong
with mine oh you got the the ear
covering okay you got the three colored
things on yeah the thing I remember the
most for some reason is those colored
buttons yeah I would say I think you got
his legs pretty good cuz now now that I
see it I remember like the lines on his
boot the boots yeah goofy yeah Jackie I
think you're gonna be surprised with how
well you did okay I hope so
oh boy yeah look at that oh wow you're
his thing formerly the buddy
I made a much more colorful like my you
you got the drab color palette and much
more
oh and I forgot he's got a little he's
such a complicated character yes I mean
like toy stuffs yeah like he has like
fingers and like he has like the shines
he has the screw holes in his legs
yeah even like the little air vents on
his forearms and like how are you
supposed to remember that it's too much
I have one brain I think it's like an
iconic look it's made up of really
simple shapes yeah so like works I think
we both know what Wally looks like in
our head yeah both of them you could
clearly look at them and say that's
Wally yeah we made a lot of mistakes
this time around we did but you know
what you don't improve as a person
without making mistakes positivity
Jackie p.m. a positive mental attitude
thank you thank you
[Music]